Tương ngày 1 tháng tắm, tập đoàn xăng dầu Việt Nam và tổng công ty dầu Việt Nam chính thức thì điểm bán xăng A,
mười tại Hà Nội, thành phố Chí Minh và Hải Phòng. Đây là lại xăng xin học 1,5% A thái nôn và chỉ mới
vấn trăm xăng khoảng chuyển thống, đuôi trình khai nhằm giảm khí thải được hạt, tiến tới mục tiêu
phát thải giòn bằng khung bệnh ám ngày khu chăm 5.
Xăng A, mười phu hợp với hồ hết các lại xe đời mới, nhất là ủ tổ và xe mai sản xuất từ năm
ngày khu chăm mười trở lại đây. Các giòn xe đặt trình khí thải 噔 dô bốn trở lên điều có thể sự dụng lại như liệu này.
Tuy nhiên, bơi xe sự dụng chế hoa khí hoặc xe mai đời cú, người dung cần thận trọng soi
ai thàn nôn có thể gây ăn món hoặc út ấm, anh rượm đến hệ thống như liệu.
Bộ công tương khuyên cáo người dân nên chào kiểu xe khương giắn sự dụng hoặc liên hệ đã li chính
hắng để được tư vấn ký thuật trước khi sự dụng.
Bởi khi điểm săng ai, mười là bước trình bị cho lộ chính áp dụng giống giống giải từ ngày 1 1.5 năm,
hành hình khu chăm 2 mề sáo theo đề sức của mộ công tương nhằm thuốc đầy trên đổi năng lượng miệnh vấn.